你看天气预报是想知道明天几度会不会下雨
当你打过卫星云图的时候
想法不太一样
你不是想听一个预测
你是想看清现在台风眼在哪
风带往哪边吹
冷风暖风是怎么弄在一起的
云图不告诉你明天一定发生什么
但那把你肉眼看不到的大气结构
拍成了一张能读懂的图
交易的指标干的就是卫星云图的事
价格在涨跌
你一眼能看到
但价格背后的结构趋势往哪个方向走
走的力度够不够
这些东西肉眼就不太容易
一次看全了指标
做的事就是把价格波动里藏着的这些结构特征
翻译成你能直接读懂的东西
但绝大多数人用指标方向一开始就偏了
打开行情软件
MACDKDJRSI全加载上
然后盯着金叉死叉问接下来是涨还是跌
你等于打开卫星云图
指着上面一块白云问明天会不会下雨
他回答不了
你不是云图不行
是你问了一个他设计上就没打算回答的问题
臣妾做不到啊
指标只能做一件事
告诉你现在处于什么状态
至于接下来怎么走
就超出了他的能力范围
它的边界就停在现在
那为什么还要这么多人把指标当预测工具用
因为金叉之后有时候确实涨了
顶背离之后有时确实跌了
你见过几次蛋蛋就自动给它们连上一根线
金叉等于要涨
但你不太会注意到
金叉之后跌的次数一样不少
背离之后继续背离的情况也经常发生
你记住的是对的那几次
忽略的是错的那几次
这在心理学上叫确认偏误
你看见你想看见的
大脑会自动帮你把反力过滤掉了
但比这个心理偏差还更要命的是
指标本身的数学结构就注定了它不能预测
所有指标都是对过去价格的二次计算
均线是过去的N天的平均值
MACD是两根均线的差值
而S是过去一段时间涨跌幅的比例
价格先动指标后算
它们之间天然有一个时间差
你再问一个用昨天数据算出来的数字
明天会发生什么
他不可能答得上来
所以把那个问题换掉
别问接下来会涨还是会跌
问现在行情处于什么状态
这两个问题之间的差别就是预测和诊断的差别
诊断之后怎么做
那是你的事
但诊断准没准是指标的事
那它能诊断什么
两件事就够了
第一趋势方向最简单的方法就是看均线
页面50在页面100上方
两条线都向上倾斜
这就是典型的多图排列
它不告诉你明天涨不涨
单单告诉你一个事实
从过去一段时间的价格结构看
买方一直跑在卖方上面
趋势方向是向上的
这个事实本身就有价值
在多头排列的环境里
你只找做多的机会
不做空不逆势
这不是预测
是顺着当前状态的方向做
什么时候趋势算结束了
等你看到两根线开始走平
缠绕甚至死叉
那时候状态就变了
你再调整
不用提前猜
等形态直接走出来
第二极端边界RSI上的80以上
意味着过去一段时间的涨势几乎一边倒
买方用力过猛了
他不告诉你马上要跌
但他告诉你一个状态
价格现在站在一个历史上容易被压回来的位置
布林带上轨也是类似的作用
价格跑到距离均值两个标准差的地方
本身就是一种偏离
在这些位置不是说不能做多
但你应该多留一个心眼
止损设得更紧一点
或者等价格回踩均线确认了再进
边界的作用不是给你一个你是信号
而是提醒你
现在这个位置比别的位置更容易出意外
这两类诊断合在一起
给你的不是知道接下来怎么办
而是知道自己现在站在哪
在趋势明确的时候
顺着方向走
在集团边界附近
守着点力气
你不预测
你只是根据当前的状态
做概率上对自己更有利的决策
讲到这里
你心里大概有个疑问了
如果指标只是告诉我现在是什么状态
那我自己看K线不也能看个差不多
我要它干什么
这个问题问得准
你看K线确实能看到一些东西
今天是涨了还是跌了
有没有大的阴线阳线
但你看不出价格变化的数学特征
均线的斜率到底是多少
波动率是在放大还是收缩
当前价格距离长期均值偏离了几个标准差
这些东西肉眼能大概感觉
但感觉会骗人
当你的单子在水下的时候
你的感觉会让你看什么都像马上要反转了
指标不会害怕
也不会贪心
它往价格上一照
该设多少度
就是多少度
这就是云图和肉眼观天的区别
你站在地上抬头看
看见乌云压过来了
感觉快要下雨了
但云图告诉你这个云环直径有多大
中心冷暖气流的强度对比是什么
你不看云图也能大概判断天气
但有了云图
你的判断更稳更细更有依据
指标给你的就是这种更稳的东西
所以下次打开行情软件
不用再追这指标
问他接下来是涨是跌
他答不上了
也别让他打
你换一个问题
现在处于什么状态
趋势方向上多头还是空头
坡度强度上是在放大还是收敛
极端边界上
价格是快到极值了
还是在中位平稳运行
把这些问题诊断清楚
你的交易就有了一个更稳的起点
至于明天是涨是跌
那是市场的事
不归指标管